[Música]
y méxico aprobó la nacionalización del
litio es la noticia de economía
destacada de la jornada para ampliar
esta información está con nosotros en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas
noches que decidieron entonces allí los
mexicanos y esto qué repercusiones tiene
para el país bueno una aprobación récord
para empezar el senado aprobó esta
modificación tan sólo dos días después
de que fuese enviada por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador con esta ley
solamente el estado mexicano podrá
explotar litio y se prohíben las
concesiones a empresas extranjeras para
extraer este mineral el presidente lópez
obrador llamó a esta ley el plan b
después de que fracasara su polémica
reforma eléctrica pero la oposición
critica el apuro con el que se gestionó
la ley y pone en duda la capacidad del
estado para asumir esta responsabilidad
el litio es clave en la fabricación de
baterías para vehículos eléctricos y
aparatos electrónicos como computadoras
o celulares
porque ahora abordemos el impacto que
tiene la guerra en ucrania para la
economía global son múltiples las
aristas este conflicto afecta a muchos
campus bueno el fondo
monetariointernacional rebajó la
previsión de crecimiento mundial del
44 por ciento que lo tenía hace tres
meses al 36 por ciento y alertó de una
gran incertidumbre por este conflicto
durante la reunión anual de primavera
del fmi del banco mundial el fondo
aseguró que la guerra tendrá incidencia
negativa en 143 economías del mundo y
que tendrá un impacto sobre el 86 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
mundial para rusia que es una de las 12
mayores economías del planeta el fm y
pronostica un hundimiento del 8.5 por
ciento de su pib para este año como
consecuencia del conflicto y de las
sanciones impuestas por otros países y
específicamente en el caso de ucrania se
esperan las peores consecuencias
económicas de la guerra su pib caerá un
35 por ciento en 2022 y los efectos se
alargarán por muchos años más afirmó el
organismo si analizamos ahora el impacto
en regiones y países eeuu crecerá un 3,7
por ciento este año y un 2 3 por ciento
en 2023 para la zona euro que es una
importadora de energía rusa las
previsiones cayeron un 1,1 punto
porcentuales para este año con dos de
sus principales economías como son
alemania e italia también con
perspectiva a la baja en el caso de
américa latina y el caribe parece
resistir a este golpe de la guerra su
previsión de crecimiento se mantuvo
intacta en 2,5 por ciento para este año
varias economías de la región son
exportadoras de materias primas que
podrían beneficiarse de alguna forma con
este aumento de los precios aunque el
fmi alertó que el principal desafío de
la región será controlar la elevada
inflación elevada inflación pero américa
latina' logra zafarse poco de otra
crisis a nivel internacional 'jorge
hablemos entonces de la importancia que
tiene esto para la industria de los
alimentos para los alimentos en general
así es que hoy el programa mundial de
alimentos de naciones unidas alertó que
ucrania está teniendo problemas para
almacenar la poca cosecha que queda en
2022 para darnos una idea de ucrania es
el quinto exportador mundial de trigo y
está entre los tres primeros de maíz
cebada y semillas de girasol en 2021 la
producción de trigo fue de 40 millones
de toneladas y otros 50 millones de
toneladas para los otros producto básico
pero la oficina de la onu alerta que el
20% de las superficies plantadas en
ucrania no se cosecharán en julio y que
la superficie de siembra de primavera
será un tercio menor de lo habitual
antes de la guerra santiago krahn ya
solía exportar casi todo su grano es
enviada a través de los puertos
marítimos que ahora están bloqueados por
el conflicto bélico ucrania es principal
proveedor del programa mundial de
alimentos que ahora dijeron están
pagando 70 millones de dólares más al
mes para comprar la misma cantidad de
alimentos que el año pasado
exportaciones ucranianas que salían por
ejemplo a través del puerto de mariupol
que está siendo asediado por las tropas
rusas hablemos ahora del gigante netflix
presentó resultados el día de hoy como
las fue pero la empresa perdió
suscriptores por primera vez en una
década y predice una mayor contracción
en el segundo trimestre en lugar de
añadir más de 2 millones de suscriptores
en el primer trimestre de este año como
anunciaron hace tres meses terminaron
perdiendo 200 mil peor aún el próximo
trimestre netflix espera perder 2
millones de suscriptores de netflix dijo
que él se debe al uso compartido de
contraseñas y a la creciente competencia
de la empresa aseguró también que además
de sus 221 seis millones de suscriptores
a nivel global hay 100 millones de
personas que utilizan su servicio y no
pagan por ello las acciones de netflix
que ya habían caído un 40 por ciento
este año se desplomaron hasta un 24 por
ciento en las operaciones posteriores al
cierre los malos resultados de netflix
también afectaron a sus competidores
disney cayó hasta un 5.2 por ciento de
warner bros que es propietaria de ex
biomax descendió hasta un 2,8 por ciento
pasemos ahora a los indicadores como las
faldas principales bolsas del mundo hoy
si hubo actividad bursátil en europa
empezamos en eeuu los tres principales
índices de referencia de wall street
tuvieron el martes sus mejores días en
más de un mes por los comentarios
moderados de dos funcionarios de la
reserva federal de eeuu en europa las
acciones registraron su peor día en dos
semanas esto por el aumento de los
rendimientos de los bonos y la
preocupación por la guerra en ucrania y
en américa latina la bolsa mexicana de
valores avanzó un 0,91 por ciento en su
principal indicador y registró su mejor
cierre desde último día de marzo muchas
gracias jorge por esta actualización de
las noticias del mundo de la economía
son las siete en punto de la noche hora
de bogotá estamos listos para el debate
aquí en directo américa
[Música]